hello everybody welcome back to let's
play okay now we just um get the tether
thing so I think we can press this now
oh I gotta go back to the other room I
don't know I lost my little Necromorph
friend so I guess I'll just do without
him I couldn't handle this anyway
goodbye me no one could take oh no no
don't be guys are trying harder to get
to me but they came not today not
tomorrow not ever yeah huh
no elevator nope not today
wait does that fire always been there I
think so
get out of there I need you what the
hell
get out of there are you kidding me get
out of
oops No terrible shot you are be
whoa
holy crap
where all this fire come from
I'm burning I'm burning let me rub okay
I'm okay
just a little fire ain't nothing to be
guess dinner will be soon
get in there oh hi they gotta be stupid
why do things got to be stupid guys I
don't know
I need a healthcare there we go and
let's see if I can drop off any goodies
Oh beauty give me that that's phat phat
damn okay all smiles
I can't alas unless there's a boss fight
coming up that I don't know about to be
fun
and if anything I still got the plasma
cutter that a lot of good that's gonna
do me oh the wall some bent
ah damn it damn it damn it damn it damn
it
hate those things ah just two of them
just enough to screw with me
no one screws with me hey I crushed you
I crushed you to pieces
why did you respawn you're crushed
smoosh no trust any of you there we can
okay and vegans on its way all functions
normal and broadcasting wideband cool
now we just have to help somebody's
listening
oh then listen to me opposition the
array receiver I thought I saw my
brother again he waved to me like
nothing was wrong
nothing is wrong you're perfectly fine
okay I should be able to leave this
channel open what the console ray
receiver isn't responding so feels wrong
the bridge we need that array online or
we can't receive signals from anyone
responding to the beacon something else
is wrong
of course something's always wrong
hey no no bodies no ha
you live up Wow we're gonna get dead
no no no no
necrotizing fasciitis no not a black one
there goes your leg there goes your arm
no I refuse ha ha try it
good thing he didn't use those bodies
against me I was too clever dispatch a
lot of good that did he pop squigglies
Squishy's here's my Squishy and I
believe it's cushy and then I will shoot
him dead
okay I should be fine where am I going
that way the way I was headed all right
and whatever timing
oh oh I'm going back okay good get me
out here where did I say I was going I
don't even remember who walsim all
I'm ready for you ah I see you I thought
you know dr. de Guiche Oh
you throw the black ones at me but they
don't even make a difference uh-huh I
heard that Gregor Lee's three guys I
hear you
oh jeez you're the head I have got your
hand now welcome here heads three the
less [ __ ] up dead how many hands do
you have not fair you shouldn't have
more than one hand and I just need to
kill one hey they'll keep it not likely
am i stupid am I no the answer's no okay
with that
oh I need pulse rounds
oh yeah
there we go that's this job Oh
pulse runs all over the place all right
and we're going this way right yep we're
going back yeah I don't know where we're
going but we're going back I'll trust
anything anymore that's the number one
rule don't trust anyone someone in there
whatever who no one you you good for you
okay all right yeah another chapter down
good job guys haha
boom chapter 7 completed into the void
where we going now I wasn't I really
wasn't paying attention I mean you could
try to tell me by yelling at your screen
but it's really not gonna make a bit of
difference sorry to say chapter 8 search
and rescue I like it I like being
rescued but I could do it by myself or
rescue everyone okay and I've been just
about all over the ship now where do
these people live I mean there's got to
be like housing for these people right
is that a place I'm gonna go eventually
maybe on it Oh meaningful things are
looking up yeah here you get docked in
the assembler yeah I don't know what it
was doing out there it must have gotten
our distress signal yeah we can't talk
to it until the comms array is fixed I'm
gonna hack the door to communications
for you oh we get in there and find the
cons control station alright let's do it
okay attencion blood nothing one who ooh
I'll see you I see you shadow I heard
that I heard it
now trust that okay I'm okay
who's out there I heard some huh hi it's
a big it's an exploding I'm not enough
boom with that boom I come
I said barrel shot what goes for comfort
stranger danger here hey stop that stop
you're wiggling that is freaky later ah
another one boink boink gone huh are
that goes good book boom got you bold
man carry explosives on your arm and I
should be able to hit you but I can
obviously not exploding
I'm sure those weeks glow to get
renovation ah what the hell
no no now you're tired
there we go and those are hot I remember
the first time I encountered one of
those it took two shots what happened to
that I guess I was with a different gun
so maybe this pulse rifle just is not
good for those things
I mean I'll shoot him in the arm but
they just they don't fall apart they're
very sturdy okay got those hoes in here
just those monsters probably aah
another box Boosh yeah there we go all
right where are we going oh okay this is
why those boxes were locked so I could
come back and still be stocked up good
for me okay where am I going
um is there anything in the bridge is
ham in there maybe back if I'm Hammond
oh I can't even control panels not even
active okay can't find Hammond must go
up this elevator up down I don't know
can't tell
ah okay uh P do Oh
level one I can't even go to level one
anymore why not I want to go to level
one
I like the door to communication is open
but I've been getting some weird
feedback spikes on the local calm okay I
think someone's listening in on us so be
careful
Hammond I don't know I doubt he could
ease bite close to dead who's out there
hol get out of here who force energy
ammo where's the [ __ ] come from I was
here before your ship is full of fragile
equipment please take care around
emergency door locks and other sensitive
devices Oh I'll smash him with my gun
that's that
Oh Oh No enjoying hot dog spit babies
acne
Oh No ah come on I'm trying to kill your
Papa here
mama are either your parents ugly sorry
you yeah explode in shame
whatever man little what are they arming
me for was that another one give it to
kidding me
always like all my bullets on these guns
there we go he'll die there you go yes
more like ah nope nope nope
two shots that's all it takes ah what oh
you still owe me it to Jeff no just
takes one insult for me and things just
explode they can't take it anymore
the shame is unbearable ah no no no
you're fat you have no hope you're dumb
and you have no friends what do you
think about that that's what I thought
all right mm not bad thank you buddy and
I need a help back there we go oh hey
buddy what the hell did you just now die
really you're that hearty whoa Wow
oh man I know oh you're the you're the
cause of it all how is freaky I was
freaky deaky ah what the hell is its
body parts whoo hey there we go
I mean why why that's freaky
anyway gah my way no don't bounce back
how dare you gotta get out of here , red
okay
blood huh save all right where am I Here
I am
boy boy oh I read your comments I know
there are more safe spots below that but
I'm just I'm set in my ways I don't care
well I care about your comments of
course I care about each one of you but
I'm not gonna change you can't make me
who audio log her text log audiences
blog first counts operator Bailey
reporting manager may later attack but
request to issue a distress call have
been repeatedly denied by captain
Mathias why he won't say it but everyone
on the bridge knows why
oh this is an illegal operation in a
prohibited system oh we've all known for
months and we kept our mouth shut
not anymore yeah Mayday Mayday Mayday
this is USG Ishimura this is tweek he'll
and things have been sabotage okay
that's why everything's broken we'll
skip it a whole comm system is offline
so I want his shadow cause a new far
Chabot Bailey out all right thank you
guys so much for watching but I have to
cut it here so I will see you guys in
the next part bye-bye